le jeudi 27 septembre golf national
accueilli la cérémonie d'ouverture de la
ryder cup ait plus de 40000 spectateurs
dans le public
une semaine plus tard l'atmosphère a
bien changé les fans ont laissé la place
à des ouvriers pour les premières
opérations de démontage
c'est bizarre ce fait étrange on est
plein plein plein de différentes
émotions on a des hauts et des débats
parce que ça s'est passé tellement vite
et vu de l'intérieur on n'a pas vraiment
vu par cette loi au total 300 personnes
sont présentes sur le site pour enlever
au plus vite les structures le dernier
camion devrait repartir à la mi novembre
là actuellement sur le parcours ce matin
il ya des gradins qui ont déjà disparu
derrière le 17 en plein démontage
derrière le 14e trou numéro 14
les grands gradins public sens ont déjà
démonté
il y a évidemment des camions qui sont
déjà partis des camions burger et cetera
je dirais un quart des jadis par les
fans de golf peuvent tout de même être
rassuré tout ne sera pas démonté ou
enlever le golf national devrait garder
des stickers de la compétition sur
certains murs le vestiaire de la team
europe sera lui aussi conservé dans son
intégralité